i'm here with the incredible gabrielle
union
who is on the cover of this month's
women's health magazine
um oh hello oh and yellow
that's our signature color here at the
show
oh i love yellow that's knife one of my
favorite colors okay
so flawless your hair cared line
um yes is it true i read that
in 2017 you launched it but then
halted it took a pause and wanted to
relaunch the business
to a certain criteria you felt was
necessary can you tell me
yeah yeah we wanted to to
i wanted to wrestle back the the company
i wanted to make it
uh black owned i wanted to redo the
formulas i wanted to partner
with one of my best friends and and uh
who's also an amazing celebrity hair
stylist larry sims
and i wanted to make sure that larry was
in the lab
creating these formulas to make sure
that things actually worked and then
once we figured that out
we wanted to make sure that it was
actually affordable um
and and we wanted to make sure that it
was accessible to as many people as
possible
um the first time in 2017 i was going
through multiple rounds of ivf and like
a lot of folks
who've experienced ivf or or pregnancy
or any time you you have
major hormonal shifts like menopause uh
i had a lot of hair loss and so i wasn't
able to authentically
you know promote the brand because i was
feeling anything but flawless
and so the 2020 version
we have amazing ingredients salon
quality
ingredients we are affordable and we are
being sold on amazon
and now in sally's um and we just wanted
to make sure that the things that worked
for me
are are available and accessible to as
many people as possible
[Music]
you